[تصفيق]
قد تبدو هذه العلامه التجاريه كعلامه
اوروبيه الا ان احذيه نيو تويستي تصنع في
مدينه الخليل في هذا المعمل الذي ينتج
قرابه 12 الف زوج من الاحذيه يوميا ويقول
مؤسس الشركه شاكر سياج انه اذا ما توفرت
القروض الماليه بفوائد منخفضه وكذلك تشجيع
الحكومه للصادرات فان ذلك سيضاعف الانتاج
بنسب
كبيره وتعاني الضفه الغربيه من تعقيدات
كثيره على مستوى الا
بسبب الجمود في محادثات السلام واعمال
العنف المتفرقه التي تقع بين الحين والاخر
وقبيل الانتفاضه الثانيه عام 2001 كانت
النيو تويستي تصدر قرابه 200 الف زوج من
الاحذيه سنويا الى المانيا ال ان الامر
اصبح مختلفا
الان عندما بدات الانتفاضه توقف شركائنا
الالمان عن استيراد منتجاتنا لانهم كانوا
يخشون على اعمالهم بسبب الوضع
السياسي وكان وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه جون
كيري قد دعى لتوسيع اطار خطه اقتصاديه
تقضي بضخ عه مليارات دولار في القطاع
الخاص لتعزيز اقتصاد الضفه الغربيه وغزه
في غضون ثلاث سنوات بينما يطالب الكثير من
رجال الاعمال الفلسطينيين برفع القيود
المفروضه على الحركه الصناعيه منذ
سنوات فبالنسبه لنيو تويستي فان ذلك يعني
رفع القيود المفروضه على بعض المواد
الكيميائيه المحظوره حيث تخشى اسرائيل من
ان تستخدم بعض المركبات في صنع المتفجرات
وفي الوقت ذاته تمنع شركات الاتصالات من
استخدام تكنولوجيا الجيل الثالث لشبكات
الهاتف النقال اضافه الى العديد من
الحواجز التي تعيق التقدم الصناعي
بالاراضي الفلسطينيه مثل الجدار العازل
ونقاط التفتيش
الامنيه حاولنا انشاء مناطق صناعيه لكننا
فشلنا وكذلك حاولنا القيام بمشاريع مثل
فنادق ومنتجعات الا اننا اخفق لان هذا
النوع من المشاريع يعتمد بشكل كبير على
عمليه السلام وهو الامر الذي اثر على
اعداد السيا القادمين للضفه الغربيه رغم
التدفق المستمر للزوار هنا في كنيسه المهد
بمدينه بيت
لحم هؤلاء الناس ياتون ليقضوا يوما واحدا
في بيت لحم وياتي الينا 2.3 مليون سائح
سنويا منهم واح 8 مليون لا يرتدون الفنادق
الفلسطينيه والسبب هو حريه الحركه
والتنقل وحريه الحركه كما يقول
الفلسطينيون لا يمكن معالجتها من دون
اتفاق السلام في حين مؤسس نيو تويستي
يكافح من اجل ايجاد اسواق جديده
لاحذيه